زيت الملا عبد الغني بردار
أو في برودواي ودين واللمسة الفرنسية
إلى الألمانية لابرادور كانامارو هويل
مدينة في قندهار
كانت الموسيقى في باماكو لارا أ
اخيرا اخماد كلام مدينة النيل
مغلق بين rioja أو في بادا
تايورو أدو المحامي زايم في وست هام في
أفغانستان المجنحة
أنها خالية من الاتاوات و bia
حي القصدير القصدير القصدير هنا أيضا
الزوج نحن فتح
أوباما عليك أن تقرأ صلاته
المجلات في الزجاج البلدي السنة ل
اربعة عشر فستانا في طريق اللحماه
وليد الملا بردار لزوجتي آني
والاستثمار في الطب المعدل في ياسين
bourouila و jurgen genova frentzen هناك
قال لي أنهم أحضروا إلى الرافعة
ناصر قندهار takaléa يان
ميشال الملا بردار فيبي لسيندي
أليس من شأنه أن يجعل mimile تمايل
croque monsieur و a مع h to
مبادرة الاصدقاء في تالين الرزوي
ليبيا السوفييتية الإثنين
طلب إذن تخطى للأسف
مجاهدين في سيارة بيس فرسنيس fessenheim
دولة السوفيتات وإحراج المسلسل
الملا محمد عمر في كندا
الولايات المتحدة
طالبان في أفغانستان
هي ليست هناك لإتقانها
في إريا Charal هو الملا بردار
رقيقة وأنا جرعة مختلفة
لجان مات الإسلامية
ال
لابرادور وباكستان
أمينابار الولايات المتحدة الديمقراطيين والخط
تحرير مدينة فارك الأمريكية
يجذب لا يحد من تأخيره و
باكستاني أنهى بشكل سيء أواتارا ميدارد
في أمريكا ولد من الحيوانات الأمريكية
أو في الحد الأقصى لقيمة mat auber ajoulots
صوفي الحلقة صعب ياسين
أفروجاك باكستان للتغلب علينا
المتضررة وفي آسيا أمريكا لديها
انتهى بشكل سيء 9 agnès arrachart الغريب
العبادة والعودة إلى الشق الشرقي
فرومنتين بسبب التفوق والإسلام
و frenzel ماري
لبي
من القاعة 3 فيديو إلى أسماء الملا
بردار رفع الرجل في بيسيجا سوريا
كرة طالبان الواطي تبيع من جديد
يصلح لهذا الحب caracalla سيم في كابول
حتى يوقفوا
كل شيء مسطح
[موسيقى]